inflation
by artificially increasing the prices
of goods and services in the world right
we're we're injecting more dollars
chasing the same level of goods and
services we are
artificially increasing scarcity
perceived scarcity right and when you
increase
perceived scarcity you are
amplifying divisiveness this natural the
natural state of man is when
everything is scarce and you really have
to fight hard just to eat
or drink water that day so it's it's
decivilizing in a way by artificially
amplifying
the perceived scarcity in the world can
you elaborate
how does inflation increase the
perceived scarcity in the world
so we could think the price itself is an
indication it's a data packet if you
will
the price is a data packet on supply and
demand right it's telling you
how much supply there is of something in
the world relative to the demand
so when you in when you print money and
artificially
increase that price it's diverging away
from supply and demand it's becoming
just a more of a product of policy
than it is of free market fundamentals
right
the more expensive something is that is
a signal to the marketplace and to
market actors that it is scarce
right right that's why uh
uh leonardo painting might sell for 16
million dollars there's only one there's
a lot of demand for it
uh maybe my numbers are off but but you
get the point
uh it's the reason mask spiked in price
after the covet announcement right there
was
supply toilet paper et cetera et cetera
so inflation
and by inflation i specifically mean
arbitrary
fiat currency supply inflation by a
legal monopoly
not um inflation's a commonly
misunderstood word
that is amplifying the perception of
scarcity
among market actors in the world and
i would argue that it actually amplifies
divisiveness
i think this is the key maybe to looking
at
the connection between the
monopolization of money and things like
cancel culture because it's increasing
the it's increasing our natural
predilection to be combative with one
another because we think
there's more scarcity in the world than
there actually is versus in a world
where you're not increasing the money
supply
prices are declining every year as
prices decline this is a signal to
market actors in the market that
scarcity is declining there's less need
to fight over things
and all of this ties back into the old
bastion saying
that if if goods don't cross borders
soldiers will
so if we're not trading with one another
if we're not acting interdependently and
we're not
um becoming more intelligent
as a market and that
increased intelligence or increased
knowledge is reflected in decreased
prices
because prices are just the exchange
ratios
of things so the smarter we can solve
problems the better we can solve
problems the less prices would be
so it induces more cooperation i love
how you tie
inflation and cancer culture together as
essentially artificial
creation of increase of conflict
[Music]
increasing artificially increasing
scarcity and thereby artificially
increasing conflict
that's really fascinating um you're
you're short-circuiting my brain many
times throughout this conversation
okay um i'm struggling this this robot
is struggling to keep up
you